there's this famous um
photograph of a falling man
so many people had to decide
when they're above the fire in the fire
whether to jump out of the building or
to burn to death
what do you make of that decision what
do you make of that situation
those people who jumped
those were acts of sheer desperation
i've i've been in fires
and and just minor burns but minor you
know in situation but i've been trapped
caught somewhat ended up in the burn
center for some nothing nothing serious
at all but like but i i for those brief
seconds half a minute was thank god if i
didn't have my fire gear on i would have
been burned to a very very horrible
level
those people
were burning alive
and they had the choice of either to
stay there and burn alive
or to
launch themselves
and some of them
i don't fault them but they they had a
few folks they won't show it anymore
because they say
i don't know why i defend some people
but
they had a couple folks that took
umbrellas and they took garbage bags
because they thought that it would slow
down their except their acceleration
rate to the ground and maybe just maybe
they wouldn't be killed
and that's to me
a true sense of desperation for humanity
to say
i'm going to die either way but let me
take my chance
and
i don't know the exact number of those
folks who did that but our first
member of the fire department killed
firefighter daniel surf from edge 216
was struck by a jumper
and one of my dear friends was ordered
to
help
take him
and they knew he was passed away because
he was hit by a a flying missile i mean
you know 120 miles an hour body lands on
you
those those two bodies are now crushed
and they were ordered to take that
firefighter and bring him across the
street to engine 10 ladder 10 it was
literally a firehouse
less than 100 yards
from the facade of the trade center from
the trade center complex they literally
right there
and there was plane parts that went into
that firehouse landed into the front
doors onto the roof but the building
itself was not destroyed
so it was used as a mini command center
for quite a while
so my friend was ordered to take
daniel's body
in respect
and bring it over to
this firehouse and give it some
semblance of dignity and lay it out i
wanted the bunk room the bunks we have
in the bunk house
and just cover it with a sheet and put a
sign
please firefighter killed do not disturb
and then we'll get to him later because
obviously this operation is going to go
on for days
and my friend who's such a great great
wonderful guy is so still to this day
filled with guilt because if they
weren't taking his body out
with the respect and dignity that they
did it took a while because
you know just it's a tough situation
his ladder company
was coming over the bridge there's a
famous picture
of ladder 118 you see this
tractor trailer fire truck it's the one
where the guy in the back also drives
and it's a zoomed out shot and you see
the brooklyn bridge and you see only the
fire truck in the middle
and you see the two burning towers in
the distance
well his engine company
was just ahead of them on the bridge
and the only reason that engine company
lived is their initial duty assignment
was to take that firefighter and bring
his body over it's like the military we
don't leave anyone behind these are our
guys
as we some guys say it's all about the
guy right next to you and nothing else
really matters
when that guy right next to you goes
down it stops you get that guy to safety
or if he's dead you get him out
so in that time frame
that saved his life
but that's a heavy burden to carry now
for the rest of your life because you
say if i wasn't helping my dead friend
i'm dead
yeah
you